people often say to me are you sorry you
played a dumb blonde
no i think she was one of the best ones
around and out there and i'm still proud
of her
you were and they fired me they fired me
for asking to be paid commensurate with
the men
that's not jay's voice uh janet get rid
of him chrissy let's hide in the kitchen
how important was it that you reconciled
with john before he passed away
i haven't talked to him for 20 years
and the receptionist said you have a
phone call she said
it's john ritter what was it like being
on set with patrick
patrick directed the bulk of the show so
all these kissing scenes that we have
we'd be
locked in and embraced but he'd be going
move to the right
we'll go to the right just a little bit
let's just get and
we would start laughing so much
how is it that you haven't slowed down
people say oh i'm gonna retire
you haven't slowed down a bit why
why i'm young at heart and healthy and
uh you know i always thought i'm 74 and
i always thought
at this age i'd be old but i'm not old
i'm chronologically old but i'm not old
and you
are also a businesswoman in this phase
of your life
yeah how is it that you became this
person who could
turn anything into gold i think you have
to look at the worst things in your life
as your opportunity so
when i was on three's company when i
signed on i just wanted the gig
and i don't even know what i signed sure
i'll sign
but at year six when i was
averaging 55 national magazine covers a
week i was on barbara walters in 16
minutes in
2020 and i had my own television
specials and
i worked with sinatra and i was the last
one to work with
john wayne and um sammy davis and all
these
legends um i i could not have improved
upon what i was doing the public
loved chrissy snow i loved chrissy snow
yeah this is the only
time when we had some time i loved being
her you know her language
and um so we went in to renegotiate in
year six because i had to my contract
was up
and they fired me and they fired me for
asking to be paid commensurate with the
men
so when alan came home from that
negotiation
he said you were fired when i walked in
this was their plan
they need you as the example
so no other woman in television will get
uppity and think that they could ask for
parody with men
and so i i was the perfect person to be
fired
i sat in my living room why
why did i do this why the greatest gig
in television why
this character that people love and i
heard a voice
and the voice in my head said why are
you focused on what you don't have
why don't you focus on what you do have
and i sat there and i thought what do i
have
and then i realized wow i have enormous
visibility
everybody in this country knows my name
would you welcome please
suzanne summers
so the power of television is is immense
and it's global
so that's how this journey began come
and knock on our door
we've been waiting for you when you look
back at that character chrissy snow
because
when people saw chrissy snow they were
like oh the ultimate blind
yeah does it make you laugh at who
suzanne summers was
and who people thought chrissy snow was
i didn't quite know then who suzanne
summers was
you know it takes a long time for us to
figure out who we are
but i did know that i had created i
thought about
chrissy snow when i was i thought how do
you make
a dumb blonde likeable and hopefully
lovable crazy
you have something to do oh yeah
come in the kitchen and show me what
you've got
and i gave her a moral code and a
circuitous route to logic
she wouldn't tell a lie and um
the audience got to know her so well
that they
started to laugh before she said it
that's what that's gold
in sitcoms that's absolute gold she was
just an incredible character to play
people
often say to me did are you sorry you
played a dumb blonde no
i i think she was one of the the best
ones
around and out there and i'm still proud
of her when i watch
her i laugh and
smile and i'm pleased so it was a good
thing
you start doing three's company when do
you know like oh my god we captured
lightning in a bottle this is the
thing like people are losing their minds
across the country year one
year one because it was tuesday night
and it was happy days laverne and
shirley three's company
that's when we would all plan our weeks
around the television schedule
and um i had this great lead up
of happy days laverne and shirley and
then three's company
just because it was a little naughty um
the the audience just loved it naughty
today it would you know
it wouldn't fly today with all the pc
stuff
i also told him that you were gay
i was just really involved in our show
and i had a child so you know i had to
um after work get home and make dinner
at 18 i got pregnant first time i ever
had sex
lucky me and then i married alan hamill
that's funny because so many people look
at chrissy snow is this
ultimately single fun yeah and you're
running home
right you're like i got i got a baby
yeah exactly exactly
wow what is it that made that show still
hold up today the writing was incredible
it was that classic comedy set up set up
beat he's got muscles all over he was
flexing his earlobes
they saw the chemistry between john
ritter and myself and so
after a while they started writing for
john and i which didn't make joyce very
happy but
uh joyce was ethel you know ethel was
the greatest set up person ever
and joyce was the greatest set up i i
don't know if she'll like me saying that
but
you need that in a sitcom you need that
balance
you talk about three's company you talk
about the the chemistry between you and
john yeah
what was that i mean what was john like
what did he mean to you
oh well uh he's the greatest physical
comic of
of our era on a par with dick van dyke
john ritter could flip over a couch and
it was choreographed like a dance
[Applause]
he did it the same way each time i
learned so much watching him
he was my real coach i would just sit
there and
watch and see his brilliance and
he had his demons you know um
when people are that nice they usually
have demons
but he the chemistry between chrissy
snow and and jack tripper was
magical then who knows what what
i think after i was fired i think he
irrationally got mad at me because he
lost his
sparring partner i would be mad too and
there was no going back
it wasn't up to me it was up to the egos
of the producers and
had they been smart that i was on
what six years it probably would have
stayed on
another six easy yeah does it make you
laugh now and you look at all the
all the pay equity stuff going on and
you think back to like
well sister i tried this a long time ago
yeah i'm the sacrificial lamb here
somebody's got to be the sacrificial
lamb that was my lesson
in when one door closes you know
crawl through the window was it hard for
you to be separated out you're with
joyce and with john all the time and all
of a sudden then
it just ends oh it was so sad it was so
sad it was like being shunned from your
family and the
whatever those producers said to them
when they went back
to the rehearsal hall um they painted me
um greedy they painted me
um she's trying to ruin the show
and so the whole show
cast and crew shunned me so i never
talked to
anybody anybody on that show
ever again ever again
i'm chrissy and this is janet oh yeah
i remember you you were at the party
last night how important was it that you
reconciled with john before he passed
away
wasn't that something i'm at the beauty
salon
i haven't talked to him for 20 years
and the receptionist comes over to me
and she said you have a phone call and
i'm all wet and i said can you take a
message she said it's
john ritter i made the same face so
i said john he said hey babe
he said i forgive you which
took a lot of maturity on my part
to say you forgive me
so i said thanks and
uh he said you know i'm doing a show
eight simple rules
and we've got this dream sequence
and i have this nightmare and in the
nightmare uh
you and joyce are in the nightmare
so i was kind of silent i said
you know the public has such a craving
for you and i
to be together again
i don't think my coming back as a
nightmare
is the best thing that we can do i said
why don't we look for a proper
project for the two of us and so we
decided to do that
let's find let's find a show for the two
of us
and then a month later he died wow
so there might have been it might have
been
there there might have been so anyway i
love
i love resolution and peace and
you know if i had stayed on three's
company
and i did do step by step for seven
years which i love
but i would have been you know just an
another actress going from sitcom to
sitcom with not a bad life
[Music]
but the life that i created i owned
you know you talk about step by step oh
frank i'm just afraid that our
relationship is purely sexual well we
can build on that
and we were actually on the set of step
by step yes i remember
and okay well then when they said
patrick duffy i said
yeah but is he funny you know
i mean i've only seen him on dallas can
he do comedy and they said well he's
really
funny on the tonight show and he was
really funny in the office so
i thought well if they're that convinced
he's got this natural
wit and and the kind of
physical uh comedic abilities of a john
ritter
so it's a real real pleasure real
pleasure to work with him
yeah who was he working with
patrick's a nice guy he's a good guy
he's an honest guy unbelievably funny
he's irreverent he's a bad boy
he's he's got it all going um
people like you said really connected
with that character though yeah they
loved your character on that and they
loved the show seven seasons right yeah
seven seasons longer than you were on
three's company yeah people forget that
don't they
it's got salt it's got fat in it i know
that's what makes it taste so good
i gave carol foster a moral code too um
what she wouldn't wouldn't do and and um
she had all those kids and yet
that show was about carol
and patrick duffy's character
trying to get laid
that's every show was about that and
whenever that
they're getting close to that moment a
kid would walk in
what was it like being on set with
patrick what was it like working with
him
well patrick directed the bulk of the
shows that we did too
so all these kissing scenes that we have
he was also directing the show so we'd
be uh
locked and embraced but he'd be going
move to the right
we'll go to the right just a little bit
let's just get and
we would start laughing so much our
humor was in sync he loved his wife
he unfortunately lost her i think two
years ago but he loved his wife and i
loved my husband
and so there was no uh jealousy of
our spouses because we're all secure in
the relationships that we had
and um uh and we had these darling kids
yeah yeah and it also was kind of
groundbreaking because you have this
woman as a cher i mean it's
it's just yeah it didn't happen at that
time yeah it was different
yeah so here you go again kind of
pushing the boundary a little bit
not realizing it though not realizing it
no i just follow the flow and when it
feels
feels right in here you go yeah yeah
so i don't know what's
next um what a privilege
it is to have written 27 books is it
kind of crazy to be that fa
like people don't understand you know
it's hard for people to get like you're
that famous that when you go
go to israel people are like oh my god
there she is
yeah is that a crazy thing like how do
you handle that that level of fame
you never take yourself too seriously
and nobody is better than anybody
the moment you start thinking you're
better than anybody you've lost
and i never i've i've never gone in that
place
you are up here on i mean this is a
beautiful
piece of land it feels like almost
mystical what is it that's so magical
about being here 43 years ago we bought
this at the height of three's company
because my son and alan had two kids and
they're all about the same age
and we were living in venice california
and when i'd come out of
the garage in the morning paparazzi were
out in front then i thought
this is not the life they have chosen
and so we
we bought this place so that they could
climb rocks
and eat dirt you know like boys should
right and um 43 years later we keep
adding to it so what a magical place and
what a safe place
you know it's god and nature you've been
married to this guy for a long time
yep yeah he's okay huh he's uh
i knew it the minute i saw him
uh he was hosting a show
allen was the johnny carson of canada he
had his own late night talk show and he
was like that guy and then he came to
los angeles he'd gone as far as he could
go in canada
he came to los angeles and he partnered
with dick clark
and um dick and alan created a show
called the anniversary game
so i was hired to be that prize model
on the very first day that he was there
and i walk
in and there's alan hamill and everybody
standing around
him and he has this thing that carson
had
that men are attracted to him and women
are attracted to him
i was so taken with him i was scared and
he came over to me
and said he
has apologized to me now for 50 years he
said
i didn't know what to say to you so i
said would you mind getting me a cup of
coffee
what an opening what an opening line and
then he asked me out and
i slept with them on the first date
because i thought i may never get
another chance
and i'm going to take advantage of this
and that's who i was going to be with
and i called my mother that day and i
said i met who i'm going to marry really
yeah
yeah here's what here's the thing okay
because i want to get this straight from
you
i don't want to get this from a book
okay you've been together
every night for 40 years now yeah
yeah yeah and and sex twice a day
well not every day but a lot of days see
see that's hormones because we're both
on hormone replacement
you're in the mood and if you're in the
mood why not
and we spend all our time together and
we have a true love affair
and what's the key to keeping it going
give each other a lot of attention
i bet we tell each other we love each
other i don't know several times a day
when you merge two families together
he's negotiating deals for you and
everything
that could be hard sometimes you had a
lot of things that could have made this
go off track
yeah but what do i know about making
deals he's a deal maker
we both know one another's strengths
and i never get in his way and he never
gets in my way he doesn't tell me what
to do in front of the camera
and i don't tell him what to do with
what he does
as a person who keeps reinventing
themselves and reinventing themselves
and finding the next turn and the next
turn the next turn
you can do this for a long time can't
you yeah
i had a residency in las vegas and
wow i love being back on stage again and
one night after the show the great thing
about live shows is
um i tr you strive to be great every
night
but there are nights when you are great
when you know you've hit
every mark and we're walking down the
hall to
our suite and i said allen
i'd like to be doing this when i'm 80.
and i wouldn't be surprised if i was on
the vegas stage at 80 i love it again
74 is chronologically old
but i'm not old